opening credits of scientific wonderment
what you mean eat drink man woman Angley
you mean ice storm Angley sounds
insensibility Angley this is like
getting Mike Trout to bunt everything
you need to know science words confusion
excitement poison violence labeled
poison instead of the specific name of
whatever poison it is negating the
purpose of a label scientists running
out of time or funding test his theories
on himself cliche yep welcome to
angley's Hulk everyone it's a comic book
movie and a Terrence Malick movie all
rolled into one so eight David Banner
saw his son skin turned green when he
took the pacifier out but I guess Bruce
never got angry again after that or his
mom never noticed the worrisome green
color appearing on his skin either that
or she's the best mom ever and the kid
never once got angry around her irony oh
you got alone with the first wave of big
comic-book movies back in the day always
looking to recreate comic book panels
somehow so you knew you were watching a
comic book movie in the event of a
nuclear meltdown get under the table
it's even better than the Indiana Jones
fridge repressed memories super Yura has
dead parents cliche main character
introduced via shaving scene cliche what
the hell is he going
that requires he ride a bike up the
lonely mountain original honk is now a
mere security guard and look Marvel Stan
Lee everyone it's 2003 so I'm sure this
will be one of his very rare cameos so
make sure you get a good look hey you
know what Jennifer Connelly I have no
clue who you hate but I hate them too
just to buy a product of my inexplicable
obsession that's emotionally Justin then
skip this movie everyone will
immediately hate brought to you by a
computer company most of those same
people already hate so all is right with
the world
I see loop the song rated this movie's
animal footage when he made Lucy you
know what kind of dignity and at least
respect the hell out of Ann leaf or at
least trying to create something
interesting with a visual presentation
once an removed
Kermit murdered I'm just saying you know
frogs start falling from the sky who do
they come to Paul Thomas Anderson 20
minutes in and this girl's most defining
characteristic is that she's been in a
relationship with seemingly every
important male character in this movie
it concerns your daughters oh man a
comic book trifecta the scientists two
experiments on himself the superheros
parents are dead and the love interest
just happens to be the resident hard-ass
his daughter Bruce Banner somehow got
into his possession a Harry Potter
photograph most photogenic couple ever
somehow failed to give this movie even a
tiny spark do you think it's just a
dream considering that they were here
when this story began it took a really
long time for Betty to tell Bruce that
she remembers having ice cream with her
father and him getting called away from
the ice cream shop Jesus both these kids
have repressed memories about what
happened that day it's a good thing they
were inexplicably drawn to each other as
adults so that they could help each
other remember movie suddenly turns into
the Time Traveler's Wife also this is a
five back of someone else's memory all
based on a photograph from Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets that was a
two and a half minute flashback man glad
you could join us back in the present
are you gonna be home Kenny time soon
what is with the damn tree fetish in
this movie don't mind me I'm just
standing outside looking at your window
for no reason with three well-trained
dogs this is meant to make you wonder if
he was even out there but I assure you
nick nolte has the power to vanish or
even teleport you might even be behind
you right now
this article is really about DNA and
stuff that gives scientists hard-ons
only problem is the article repeats
itself in the paragraph below this
picture making journalists lose theirs
what you might as well have said Bruce I
am your father
wait was a highly trained scientist just
working on something electrical without
locking out and tagging out OSHA is
gonna be pissed but good for the plot
since the resulting gamma radiation is
what Bruce needs to finally become the
character promised by this title
remember my bad knee that's my good name
wouldn't you now not have any particular
good knee after this gamma blast aren't
both knees equally good lizards
jellyfish more frog murder fungi the
earth now I understand everything how
the fuck did you get dogs in here and
there was not Krenzel oh it's banner
holy Sh
I'm barely registering the nick nolte
and the three dogs after I just woke up
much less my real name so why don't you
explain the Nick Nolte first and we'll
go from there chief and put me away for
30 years just enough time for me to get
out right before your big honks ient if
ik breakthrough a moment funny thing is
he called me
ah another eating establishment make
sure you don't get the ice cream Betty
that's the dessert of abandonment Bruce
starts thinking and rapidly edited
montage complete with different film
stock and exposures okay so why is he
getting this angry again yeah yeah you
Avengers fans are gonna reply well he's
always angry and while that's a fun line
from a completely different actor nine
years after this movie in a time when
Avengers was just a dream this makes no
sense he gets a visit from his dad
leaves the hospital draws his own blood
and then thinks about stuff and becomes
a drunken stepfather he has no reason to
be angry
maybe sad confused where does this come
from Willy realizes bana needs to turn
into the Hulk or else it's just a story
about two scientists with repressed
memories who banged in a sex cabin one
weekend as always Banner managed to buy
the genes that could expand several
waist lines whenever honking occurs in
Lee lit destruction gets separated into
multiple panels so you can feel like
you're reading a comic book underneath
the covers past your bedtime without a
flashlight Atlas Shrugged the difference
between super hero and super villain is
throwing a big scientific thingy outside
and missing a cop by a couple of feet or
you know one bad decision if you're a
cop in Fast & Furious the don't jump off
the building in a rage come straight
home and go to bed how did no one see it
how can you be a rage monster destroying
everything in sight and suddenly feel
the need to go to sleep I wonder how
much money Pepsi spent to get amp energy
drink in this movie over Monster Energy
so you wanna know what's wrong with him
they'd fix him change him I guess David
Banner learned a bunch from magneto
while in prison I was always told my
father was dead don't play with me four
years old you shot Ross expects Bruce to
remember something just because he was
four and expects him to know what it is
second of all it sounds like you saw it
too mister military man is it at all
which would mean your memories of this
event are far and away superior to
Bruce's they're also pretty terrible at
your job if you can't find the man your
daughter just visit it or find him in
the same way she did employment records
at the lab I'm just saying one more time
oh the world just flipped into reverse
but you guys feel that but you live for
the rest your natural life peak reenact
okay I'm guessing they get the go-getter
part but let nothing stand in your way
part it's kind of lost on dogs I'm
assuming and as for Betty I'm sending
her surprise visit from some four-legged
friends of mine they picked up her scent
from some clothing and will somehow find
her from my place to Hertz miles and
miles away
Glenn is maniacally angry at some bulls
so that he can stimulate Bruce's rage
meter to honk out again
Talbot survives this all cuz that dick
to his neighbor's here you won't be able
to understand this better if I lift you
and set you on the hood of this car this
is not Mark Ruffalo wait how did the
dogs make it this far tracking her scent
did she walk all the way here through
the woods she drove in a car ring so
she'd have to leave behind a trail of
skin cells or perspiration while in that
car that a dog could somehow track
outside from David's house okay I bet
the dogs gave up and made a few phone
calls to find this address why doesn't
the movie show the dogs on peds jump
completely over the pond in one shot
when it dropped this way and cut like
this it's easy to forget they just
jumped over an entire body of water I'm
sure there were special effects problems
but these dogs abilities are completely
neutered by cutting it like this also of
all the bad decisions this movie made
Hulk dogs was one of the most bad Paul
punches this dog in the dick but just
think the special effects person had to
specifically create balls on this dog so
that you could barely see it in a darkly
lit blink and you'll miss shot they
spent hours on balls and it lasts a
second mostly boring Hulk movie abruptly
goes full scooby-doo at the halfway
point with Hulk dogs maybe worse than
the bat nipples people I'm talking
stupid does not play on film at all wait
how did the dogs get onto trees that are
ahead of home mid jump after they
collided with each other at this point
these dogs are simply annoying they pose
no real threat to Hulk so this is
masturbation why can't the souped-up dog
break into this car dog disappears into
a green cloud of smoke as it flies in
midair I guess it ran it hit points all
during this fight the movie constantly
cuts back to Jennifer Connelly's
reaction shots as if her agent made it
clear to angley that she must be
accounted for every two seconds in any
scene she's in so the first time Bruce
hulked out he went to bed with his
always fitting no matter what jeans but
now he's somehow fallen out of them
because it's more realistic that way
Oh Bruce always better to find out
beforehand that your partner is into
auto-erotic asphyxiation
I'm scared I need your help snitches get
stitches Betty movie inspires Iron Man
to set a lot of action in a desert
military porn
no one will be seated during the
exciting Bruce Banner is transported by
military vehicles
see then why did you call her dad and
represent you of all people should have
known help was not in your father's
agenda looks like they decided to use
the guerrilla footage of Nick Nolte in
his trailer
oh so the gamma radiation turned David
Banner into the t1000 David's new power
helps murder the security guard in an
entirely random manner targa believe he
thought i'll fuse with the grading floor
trip him up and then bludgeon him with a
machine i've also fused on to it's
almost too easy
or that Indiana Jones survived in that
bridge this is my glasses man how the
fuck would she know we spent an entire
two minutes on this damn scene and over
an hour getting to it you'd better
remember something damn it damn it he
didn't remember something tell it
actually wants him to turn into the Hulk
while locked inside a small room with it
can you actually tell your biological
self not to get angry even if everything
inside you says get angry I did welcome
back wait how did he know she'd be here
how long was he waiting
why was she staying at the cabin during
the whole smashes dog scene this seems
like location convenience for everything
plot and action related but I have good
god this movie is nothing but flashbacks
this is the worst of origin stories when
you have to sit through mounds of
exposition and contemplation to get to
the fucking thing you came to see the
movie fool and even when we have seen
the Hulk in this movie it's some sort of
total bullshit that was basically made
up on the spot it was she nice
well that's generally what happens
during a stabbing this distant nuclear
testing explosion is green because Hulk
Ben no that must be some jumbo nightmare
you just had you mean you remembered
what happened to him at the exact same
time his dad was telling the story
inconceivable I may not realize what
I've gotten myself into face no wonder
this company can't get anything done
right they're sitting around watching
home cartoons all day it's the comic
books come to life on the big screen to
look like the comic books again though
the entire facility not earlier when
Hulk first got free but now after he's
already killed some fools why don't you
use the containment foam again because
he broke out of it unusual circumstances
I know but it's a total failure the guy
who invented it has been fired
so why the fruitless bullets shut your
mouth that's why he's supposed to be
three different reaction shots from Ross
while his soldiers failed to take down
the Hulk but we're still hearing the
bullets in real time so I'm confused
this is like three continuity errors all
in the same shot most of the time these
panels are worthless
they need a wide shot of the guy
shooting with two close-ups of the same
guy shooting this makes me wonder what
Brian DePalma would have done with this
movie this is still working this is also
very Iron Man like did Jon Favreau watch
lots and lots of pulp before making Iron
Man Hulk flashback or should I say smash
back yeah probably not no well now wait
a minute those literally are the Jericho
missiles from the first Iron Man movie
these two movies started out as the same
script punk murder that's cute but the
show will never fit through the now bent
barrel so this is more of a symbolic
gesture than anything else oh well I
guess it's okay Hulk did that now that
we see this guy is completely okay after
being slung 300 yards in a tank but what
about his buddies though movie sweeps
their deaths under the rug mr. president
I have some bad news sir damn did this
have to happen during the president's
fishing trip that's bad timing and makes
him look so foolish
wait 2003 I think I get it now it's a
bird it's a plane it's soup wise every
part of him green except the nipples
which are purple score for this scene
provided by Sting and that one algerian
singer who sang a duet with him on that
one song that was kind of popular
initiate an immediate evacuation the
vicinity of grid coordinates shakes five
we suspect the halt may be located near
penis and to vagina Rock right right
that geological shrine to threesomes you
got it
you're not a fun guy in this movie could
cure all diseases so far guns and tanks
haven't been able to take this guy down
the best thing has been that containment
foam but it doesn't exist anymore
maybe helicopters yeah we'll try
helicopters today I learned you can bite
the explosive head off a missile without
it exploding but when you spit it at a
helicopter that explodes immediately
Hulk jumps past helpful signs that
update us on his progress oh yeah you
knew who couldn't pass up the Golden
Gate Bridge in this trip to San
Francisco it's known as the monument
that attracts mutants of all ages hmm
for a movie Marvel doesn't seem to want
to acknowledge this movie sure inspired
a lot of modern marvel movie moments oh
it's that Carl Union thing we are two
people related the stream symbolizes a
lot mostly obvious Ness why the hell can
he get out from under the road he's the
Hulk he eventually gets out but why does
he spend all this time destroying the
streets of San Francisco
so it's King Kong basically the thinnest
transformation doesn't leave him naked
this time meantime if he does anything
but sit there in that chair and turn on
the juice he'll be incinerated
immediately Jesus that is a ton of
exposition to the person who knows
exactly what will happen when you turn
on the juice as far as Bruce plays the
pronoun game so that his dad will have
to figure out who her is I still won't
tell you your mother's goddamn name Oh
what do you know electricity makes him
stronger I guess we couldn't get enough
of this later when we saw Doctor Doom in
electro more worthless shooting I have
nightmares about impotent gunfire it
might be a Freudian type dream but I
think it's literal sir I've located them
on radar paralyzed because we definitely
have the ability to stop him this time
you think you can live with it take it
at this point I don't know why David
isn't content being the mutinies become
guy can turn into anything he wants yeah
he wants the whole power for some reason
I guess to rob banks probably to rob
banks but this frog definitely enjoys it
when bruises angry also the movie cuts
away dramatically because the guy's
stealing medicine is definitely going to
get his comeuppance but considering the
two hours of 12 minutes I just sat
through basically nothing the fact that
they don't show Hulk using his powers
for good is a real letdown just you me
your balls in this drawer
[Music]
you should be getting worse getting
better it's not that easy being green
having to spend each day the color of
the leaves your hostesses unit is how
all the files of the whole park it tells
you everything